foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by pressure.com
you don't have to be a freeloader your
whole life the good news is that you can
support this show and the fight by
buying some really cool clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a nice sip that was good it's a
little bit of a melancholy sip
today
so look we're going to to touch on some
news because obviously the millie the
blinking situation unbelievable pretty
big from yesterday touch on that but
uh
i don't know this isn't necessarily
something that people do for clicks we
wanted to really do a tribute here to
norm mcdonald and let me explain to you
why he's been one of the single biggest
influences
on me professionally
uh on this show
i've talked about it at length as a
matter of fact we'll show some clips of
how many times i've
talked about
uh
one my top two guests that i ever wanted
to get were were uh nor mcdonald and
alice cooper yeah yeah and so that's the
real tragedy in all this is i'll never
get to have him on the show it's true
truly yes there are other ways not to
come on the show norm you know that's
the thing
you don't know who you hurt cooper
yeah yeah well you want to watch out he
won't because his publicist doesn't like
me um so we're going and not only that
but i think a lot of people now jump on
this bandwagon look keep in mind that
norm mcdonald
was reviled not very long ago by the
metoo people yeah by the uh uh i don't
even know what hashtag we're talking
about but people now act as though they
appreciated the brilliance that was norm
people don't realize also uh what a
devout man of faith that he was yeah
he tried to avoid politics but it was
pretty easy to pick up on
where he lined up
so we're going to be talking about that
today quite a bit and i want to paint a
more full picture of who the man was and
and hopefully there's some people out
there who maybe don't uh don't know
about him too much haven't appreciated
him as much as you should and and really
he should go along certainly with the
greats i would put him in funniest man
that ever lived i've said that many
times i've said nor mcdonald's the
funniest man who's ever lived and i've
said that nick depaul is one of the
funniest mans right now doing stand-up
comedy and i usually say it every time i
bring on nick depaolo yeah and he
considers a comparison even
in honor
so i want to hear from you look comment
just comment down in your favorite norm
joke
pause this and comment your favorite
norm dog this is actually an important
experiment okay i want all of you to
pause this because we are going to show
you the best of norm yeah some of these
some of these clips are longer because
norm takes his time yeah
he's a slow burn but i want you to pause
leave a comment with your favorite norm
joke before you watch the rest of this
show
uh but to lead this off
i just want to show you this is this
must be from somewhere in the 90s nor
macdonald and dennis miller keep in mind
this is before dennis miller even
realized before am radio dennis miller
before dennis miller even knew that he
was more right leaning and nor macdonald
had not been open about anything
politically yeah
but again this is why comedy is is so
interes it's such a window into people
sometimes that doesn't mean that all of
us real sometimes it's just jokes just
like alice cooper lyrics doesn't mean
that's actually who he is these are just
jokes but sometimes you can see
that little shimmer of oh that's what he
thinks
not to mention
this is a joke that may immediately get
us banned from youtube which again
proves my point
uh
but here he is on dennis miller
saying something you could never say
today on air even on hbo talking about
gay pride have you ever done anything
in your long and storied career that you
consider specifically to be in bad taste
as you look back on it maybe at the time
you thought it was a good play but you
look back on you think that was in bad
taste well sometimes like in stand-up
i'll do jokes that are uh that i like
one time i was doing this thing in san
francisco and they were all gay uh
people in the audience they told me so i
figured out in san francisco no
so i figured i'd do stuff about gay
people so that they could relate to yes
warm up
they love that and so i was talking
about because i went to this gay pride
parade and i saw in it there were these
old men and old ladies like with these
signs that said we are proud of our gay
son
you know and so i was saying that's an
odd thing to be proud of you know
because it's not an achievement you know
it's not like something you work all
your life to be gay or anything like
that
and i i just wanted i just i had a hard
time believing that these 50 60 year old
men are actually bragging you know at
work like they're hey bill you know uh
my kid oh my god we're proud of him
johnny he uh graduated from harvard you
know a first in his class you know what
i mean and now he's articling over to
love him and oh yeah he loves [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he can't get enough in his mouth
[Applause]
the maturation of you as an artist to
realize it took you nine and a half
minutes to get around to the second cook
stuff
it's beautiful to see you
comfortable in your own skin marmi all
right
that's a legend that's quintessential
dennis miller i'm surprised you can
throw in some more references yeah
that's uh it's really nice to you coming
into your own skin almost like imax
directors back when they were doing
hidden earth part four where they had to
replace it with little duodenum over
there from czechoslovakia you know what
i'm talking about he's a cool cattle
like the cut of his jet
shot
let's make sure too if we need to bring
up those clips and you know you can
bring us down a little bit because norm
is is uh the highlight here and i'll
show you my favorite norm joke in a
little bit yeah what's beautiful about
normal light is my favorite norm joke
ever
it's very very short okay so he would
have short rapid fire punch lines and
then some long sorry anyways before we
get anything gerald a how are you sir i
am better than you i'm actually feeling
great well you sound better i'll see you
better i'll tell you that in a second i
don't i don't have the kovid by the way
let me just show this to everyone i'll
i'll pass this around my wife tested
positive stephen that's a pregnancy test
yeah let's pass around yourself it looks
like you are pregnant well i was
wondering why didn't i hear you
late turns out i'm a man uh see if your
choice now
[Laughter]
now let's uh
quarterback how are you i'm doing good
uh i mean except for doing well but
we'll allow it because we're losing yeah
yeah losing norm man it's it was that
was rough yesterday i saw that and i was
like it was the first time i've ever uh
uh actually like cried at a celebrity
celebrity death yeah it's pretty close
i've ever had a girl in the eighth grade
who cried when jeff gordon died and she
didn't even watch nascar not jeff gordon
who was the getting nascar democrats
maybe that's it i don't know no it was
some driver who died it was 100 percent
dale earnhardt jailer
whoever it is junior's still around
earnhardt died at daytona yeah let me i
got a lot of plates at home
i'll bring them in i'll show you let me
know i don't know but whoever died when
i was in junior high and i always think
it's weird but again because norma's
been something that means so much not
only to me personally but also to people
out there he was the he was one of the
last vanguards of comedy yeah and he was
one of the last vanguards of comedy who
had respect from his his comedic peers
and so it carried some weight and then
of course they tried to character
assassinate norm because you can't have
someone like that so don't let people
today jump on the bandwagon
when they were trying to destroy
everything that norm helped build up and
we'll we'll sort of paint a portrait
here that i think has been overlooked
and dave linda was here how are you ahoy
i'm good and norm's yeah i'm still on
that norm is uh it's a we can joke about
norm dying that's how he would want it
he would we have to laugh a little bit
because that's what he was all about
yeah it was exposing the darkness the
light yeah i i
don't know it sucks
what's so amazing about him is
everybody yesterday on twitter was
fighting as usual right just armchair
whatever and then norm died and it just
took over yeah it was one of those
things where even if people may have
gone against him whatever it was it was
just nice to see a minute of unity yeah
off of a guy yeah i think that's true
and then most of us always agree with
you as a legend yes then he was off the
trending list like within five hours and
he was like oh
really wouldn't
nice i don't know when aaliyah is
trending and people mourn her i don't
know how many years after her death
whereas aaliyah died because 20 years
ago without her samsonite luggage yep
look it up
it happened look it up the pilot's lisa
lopez wasn't it
the left eye lopez no no
was trending again because she died she
died a long time ago oh yeah i'm like i
know we didn't get queen of the damned
too wait i thought lisa how did left eye
died she died i forgot about that plane
crash was it a playing card her name is
why yeah jeff pirate tlc come on what
she was missing
you don't remember the eye patch one
from the tlc video no
in the overalls no yeah come on the most
doable i thought it was a fashion party
three like nelly with the band-aid which
i'm pretty sure nelly had the band-aid
because he had a bad zit and needed to
cover it up temporarily but then was
like nah it's my thing i'm going to wear
a band-aid does it get some alopecia
that's gay and he was like nah man it's
a fashion thing and then they lift it up
and they see like a little white like oh
damn
well i believe left eye was either
married to or dating a football player
and she burned his house down too oh
well that's good another one lost too
soon
i was wrong it was a jeep accident
that's what i thought it was all right
let's stop talking about other
people let's stop talking about other
people who don't matter uh so i tested
negative here for covid i want to be
very clear i'm pretty sure i have a
sinus infection okay i was in a room
with four people yesterday who all had
covid and a fan blowing particles in my
face my wife tested positive for covid
two days after i was feeling the
symptoms so i got the symptoms
of a sinus infection she really wasn't
having them she just tested just because
she was worried that she'd been near me
and i will tell you she's post-pregnancy
so we didn't do all the stuff but we
were doing some stuff the marriage bet
is undefiled so i don't know how i
didn't give him anything you guys can
all see this is my third
negative
test what's your blood type is that do
you think that has anything to do with
it no idea but i did hear on cnn this
morning they were talking about how your
t-cell count may be what uh confers some
people natural immunity oh and there is
some concern with the vaccine and how it
may interact with t cells we talked
about this on cnn i can't confirm
anything so here's what i will say i
woke up this morning
feeling way worse yeah i mean i woke up
this morning and my throat was on fire
and i thought oh no
this is what it is
but don't worry it's okay turns out what
happened was i had ordered indian food
i'd ordered the lamb vindaloo up to
spice level 10.
oh and
uh i had been burping in my sleep and so
it burned my throat and only when i
farted and it burned my butthole
did i realize what was going on
and that i was completely safe saved by
a farm true story i woke up
oh i forgot about the
it's the curry wow what a terrible night
for your wife
no no no i'm not sleeping there because
uh right now i'm still in the same bed
with the coconut well originally i was
sent away it's defiled that marijuana
that has been defiled by coven i was
sent away but then she tested positive
yeah and i'm like what the hell am i
away for why don't i get to sleep in my
bed the other one is positive so all
right
we're gonna go back to norm here in uh
in a little bit
uh but first we're gonna talk about the
uh the gavin newsom thing really quickly
and the millie uh blanken situation i
have some strong thoughts on it
and then i want to get to honoring norms
deserve to be honored yeah that would
probably be norman they say that
marriage bed uh isn't defiled but uh you
know i've done my best there you know
i don't know now that they have gay
marriage have you seen what they do in
hotels
i don't know that seems the theme's like
uh jesus would be up there saying oh
that's mighty defiling yeah
except for you guys
um
okay so uh
it appears that friend of the show larry
elder is not going to replace
uh you know gavin newsome's governor
he got 40 was it 46 of the vote yeah
pretty high actually
caitlyn jenner got one
ooh well that makes sense
wow that's right continual uh hit and
run uh former male track athlete now
menstruating uh female caitlyn jenner
shocked voters by only receiving one
i think she went right into menopause
directly into it yeah that's what those
hot flashes are yes yeah
i forgot she was even running yeah me
too
she was a joke for a little while you
know then she's like i'm on the ballot i
might as well stay there good try
running from biology you know
don't catch me there
run over here yeah
i'm gonna be over there oh she's ran
from it so uh and it appears that larry
elder you know some people are trying to
say that larry elder is gonna
here's a clip
so we have lost a battle but we are
absolutely going to win the war
call the violence oh oh i heard it
is this the wrong clip yeah
and here's gavin spinning um you know
everything that is ruining the united
states i should say maybe not ruining
everything in the united states of
america but certainly california once
wonderful state
has a victory i want to focus on what we
said yes to as a state we said yes to
science such a good-looking guy yes the
vaccines
he said yes to ending this
we said yes to people's right to vote
without fear of
fake fraud and voter suppression
we said yes
to women's fundamental constitutional
right to decide for herself
what she does with her body i love what
i just said we said yes to vaccines
talking about mandates yes to diversity
we said yes to inclusion so let me be
clear what that means we said yes to
vaccines what does that mean we said yes
to forcing people to be vaccinated we
said yes to women's constitutional
rights what does that mean we said yes
to the right to women to end the life of
another human being with separate dna
with separate heartbeat with separate
toes fingers sexual reproductive organs
we said yes to all those things and by
the way i'm pandering about all of it we
said yes to diversity which means we
said yes to record number of illegal
immigrants crossing the border
committing crimes not being part of the
vaccine mandates by the way though they
are uh required to uh actually take
doses of ivermectin to make sure you
have parasitic worms we said yes to
driving down american wages we said yes
to effectively creating a new slave
labor class here in california and we
said yes to sending business after
business
to texas including the one that uh
innovated
electric
environmentally friendly cars and
tesla's we don't know how that one got
away from us but i won oops and we said
no to a black white supremacist yes
the first of its kind really he's he's
the black face of white supremacy he's
the reverse mickey mouse well they also
said yes to more fires less water power
that's really not able to be kept on
most of the time and yes to stupidity
yeah you hate your cities that you live
in and yet you voted for a democrat
again you get what you deserve
california i'm sorry yep yep
yes to tom selleck's avocado farm
where he can take so much water
yes
oh so it looks like uh not all your
votes are in this the gap is 34 to 64.
yeah still more to be counted yeah well
it seems tough to close for elder to
finish last night it was like 46. i
think there were two things actually so
i think you're right on the 46. one was
do you want to recall him or not you
actually had to vote for that on this
ballot oh and that was that gap right
and then if you do who do you want to
replace him and it would be well see
this is what this is what that tells you
it tells you that just like uh
uh who was it who talked about this
it might have been larry it might have
been larry elder himself when joe biden
came in when elizabeth warren came in
none of them said that that newsome did
a a good job for helping or not at all
none of them said that his policies have
been effective they said you know we
trusted the science so when people are
polled on should we recall gavin newsom
in california mind you 46 say yes so
that tells you that he's done a bad job
that the policies aren't there then when
they're forced to decide between gavin
newsom
and larry elder and the media attack
machine can do their job of actually
convincing californians that larry elder
is a white supremacist he gets less of
the votes in other words there is no
policy there is no framework for the
left to stand on gavin newsom knew it
and so what did they have to do had to
be racism sexism homophobia transphobia
that's what they and that works in
california i think it's going to work
less and less across the country so
there's a silver lining there 46 said
gavin newsom you suck and then
a significant portion said uh you say
that the black guy's a white supremacist
well this is california i buy it yeah
it's more proof of america being divided
in half yeah yeah i don't think it's
more proof of america being i think it's
more proof that the left exclusively
exclusively this is not a right but it's
for white guys pretending to be virtuous
yes that too because that's what
happened with biden but they exclusively
campaign on identity politics racism
because that's all they have what is
biden going to let's say elections were
held right now yeah what is biden going
to campaign successful economy americans
being safer yeah right better better
foreign policy putting in a catheter
right copenhagen's gone right no no no
no no no no
not gone so we're just gonna force you
to get mandates unity
do we think that's a in other words even
the sort of intangibles that he's going
to unify the country what could biden
campaign on so i guarantee you what he
will campaign on in 2024 whoever it is
doesn't matter if it's ted cruz if it's
run the sentence if it's donald trump
will be racist sexist homophobic for
crying out loud they tried to say that
larry elder was worse than gavin
newsom's wife when rose mcgowan i was
just listening this somewhere in the
media yes rose mcgowan said you know
gavin newsom's wife and their law firm
tried to offer me hush money yeah
and i don't know if it's true or not but
whatever happened to hashtag believe all
women the point is they didn't even
cover it
mcgowan's like the one right yeah they
didn't even cover it but here's what's
important about that they try to say
well really if you think that gavin
newsom is better for women than compared
to and heard them on the radio play a
clip of larry elder saying well you know
at least donald trump has done more for
uh for for uh fat overweight women
getting them off the couch with these
marches than uh any uh michelle obama
fitness initiative has ever that's like
they're like he hates women so you're
comparing a joke about fat people
to rape
well this is where we are they cannot
win on policy they try and tell you look
we're more popular in policy because
most americans consider themselves
pro-choice but then when you get down
hold on a second heartbeat oh yeah that
makes sense hold on a second where
should abortion be allowed it's nowhere
near aligned with the dnc platform hey
are you pro-immigration sure uh then we
got knuckles down okay are you
pro-sanctuary city well no of course not
should we be able to deport people here
who are here illegally and are
committing crimes well of course we
should be able to should people at the
border be forced to pay uh forced to
sign the guest book be forced to pay
taxes of course they should so they use
buzzwords
both to try and fool their base into
voting for them we're pro-choice we're
pro-diversity and then they change
language to try and make you hate the
people
who they're running against they're
racist sexist transphobic homophobic i
don't know i think the guy who's more
racist is the per is is the person who
uh first off accuses the black guy of
being a white supremacist and accuses
him of not being black enough and who
has supporters who dress up as gorillas
and egg the black candidate i think at
the very least you can make more of an
argument that's racist i think that's a
reasonable position by the way they
always say that we are anti-immigrant
too it's like no it's just anti-illegal
immigration you're trying to smear us
with this stuff guys you have nothing to
run on vote for gavin is a vote for
diversity i say my house has never been
cleaner
they're really good i don't even know
what that's all right so uh by the way i
hire illegals to clean my house
careful careful you say that on this
they're sweet yeah if you say that on
this show you will be audited if you're
a democrat it's fine but yeah i'm
already i've experienced it oh yeah it's
too late the second i got this show i
got audited
all of a sudden my phone rang and
they're going through my records i'm a
comic i don't have anything to hide
but
i can't go for it
um hey by the way if you want to support
the the show because we're not making
anything on youtube crowdershop.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas
dot com oh i didn't know we had a little
stinger i just thought it was yeah well
this is my favorite shirt and uh yeah
yeah it's a fun one i can only get there
at crowder shop it uh
hit the notification bell if you're
watching because descriptions don't
really work and
we're live monday through thursday 10
a.m eastern that's the best way to
support the sh just watch it just tune
in watch live you know you'll never miss
it comment uh well yeah we'll be taking
your chat later on mug club we're going
to do an entire segment which we
couldn't do on youtube because it's
sexist about
all of our childhood crushes when we
first realized that we were
filthy straight men also uh
also uh angel eyes over here uh who
who's helping out to run the uh the the
sound she's going to include her mail
crush where she realized she was a
filthy ciscom woman
oh
kirk cameron
[Laughter]
only fits in the left behind i think
she's right or strong i think she's a
little uh she's a little tall cody she's
5'3 so uh
more vaccine fascism is what's going on
right now
um and i mean this fascist people throw
around the term fashion like what about
forcing someone to get a vaccine and
this is this is something where i was
there talking with people yesterday when
kova tests all the stuff
and no one disagreed and you had provax
that you had pro-vaccine people you had
i will say anecdotally most people have
been vaccinated
we tested positive uh certainly a
percentage of them uh we know this
across the country this is no longer
conspiracy we've acknowledged it
but no one disagreed with the fact that
it is
absolutely insane and like you were
talking about divisive to
label
any americans who say covet is real it's
a real virus and it affects certain
people
really negatively for example far more
lethal for old people than the standard
flu
won't get into numbers with young people
and infants but it's a real virus and it
affects certain demographics very
negatively and that needs to be taken
seriously precautions need to be taken
to protect those people who are most at
risk
also not a reason to shut down the
economy destroy it for generations to
come and certainly not a reason to
effectively forcefully evaporate
people's individual freedoms to take a
vaccine or not and
anyone who says
hey
vaccine probably safe
but we don't have any long-term studies
and if you say that you're lying because
you couldn't possibly
doesn't make them an anti-vaxxer it is
divisive to consider someone who
maintains all those points of view
as an anti-voxer and every single person
there who i was there with yesterday
getting my test the whole clinic all
this
agreed i said yeah yeah this is really
bad i can't believe it yeah typically we
this is the medical this is the science
position is to wait for long-term data
yeah right we don't we don't spend the
rest of yourself
well my wife my wife went and got the
monolith antibodies and um
it says on there if you are pregnant or
breastfeeding that the risks may
outweigh the rewards and so you probably
should talk with your doctor but in the
absence of speaking with your doctor not
do it i'm going it doesn't say that with
a vaccine no no
you read the sign
that's not it's it's not i get it it's a
baby let's not just pull me off with the
punch lines here i'm sorry no it's okay
because this is this is this is
important right now we're talking about
the vaccines like my wife was there my
wife is breastfeeding she had this stuff
so this matters my wife has to know do i
need to stop breastfeeding yeah my wife
is doing it can i take what happens if i
take the antibodies right what happens
if i take any treatment same thing with
the vaccine these are questions that
need to sorry they need to be [ __ ]
asked and they've always been asked if
someone is pregnant or breastfeeding the
standard of proof is you need to prove
beyond any doubt not even reasonable
beyond any doubt whatsoever that this
will not cause harm to a pregnant or
breastfeeding woman and they still apply
that to monoclonal antibodies which by
the way if you go in and i highly
recommend it if you do test positive has
the shortest list of side effects i have
ever seen from any medication in my life
and that includes my daily zyrtec
one of them was a smile
but all of a sudden with a vaccine it's
out the window yeah no that pisses me
off because my wife doesn't even get an
exemption with work for being somebody
who was breastfeeding at the time and
then we find out she's pregnant and
works like hey sorry the work literally
responded i'm not going to say who
literally responded prove to us that it
will hurt you that's that is what
show us the study that tells us that
this is a problem for pregnant or
nursing i'm like
are you insane well they don't have the
study that's exactly right yeah one of
the nurses came and said oh oh you're
pregnant and uh you have a covet you
should get the vaccine right now you
know it'll protect you and then
a doctor said wait wait wait that nurse
said that the vaccine was
treatment
so i have to worry about my my wife
being healthy yeah because of a nurse
with an opinion
yeah anyway all right so this is thing
fauci now said that there may be
vaccines for so i use the term fascism
actually when you're talking about
ultimately checkpoints for people in the
united states not even traveling
internationally
on roads
mandates for interstate travel here's
gepetto himself this is very common
practice now in europe i've just been
traveling all over europe you can't get
on a plane without having some kind of
proof that you're negative it seems to
me crazy that a year and a half into
this you can still i can still get on
plane to boston or california and
nobody's going to check me do you think
that needs to change
well that's under consideration
certainly i mean i have been asked that
question and it actually
got got some play in the press when i
made the answer i think that if in fact
it is seriously considered it's on the
table we're not there yet in fact if you
look at the six point program that the
president came out with a couple of days
what we were talking about with travel
was doubling the fines of people who in
fact are traveling and don't get tested
and i and i believe that the idea about
requiring vaccination for travel is
something that is on the table for
discussion it has not been decided yet
answer a question once in your life yeah
dude every single answer he's ever given
is that where it's like i don't know
well i actually did answer but i was
just impressed he did answer this
question not long ago that's a good
point uh overlay c that there would not
be any vaccine oh good hold up so now
he's saying
we can answer this again we'll be
getting to the norm tribute but it would
be oh okay so now uh uh uh
you know dr anthony fauci there you know
the uh the only scientist left
you know it says that uh we're gonna
have interstate travel and so the advice
to people out there uh particularly to
people advocating for these vaccines and
mandates uh is uh what we need you to do
is go south on the 405 and take an exit
as you go east on the 101 and then
you're going to take and exit it north
to poverty boulevard pull up to the stop
sign roll it be sure to always roll the
stop sign right of course you don't want
to you want to stop you don't want to go
then uh continue down toward uh
manhattan beach and go [ __ ] yourself how
about that
you know and you're wondering where this
is going and then oh i see norm yeah
thank you i appreciate that that's
unbelievable that we're taking advice
from somebody who says europe has it
right by the way and i can't just travel
from place to place i have to show proof
of vaccination he's like yeah i think
that sounds about right no this is a
completely different country in europe
that didn't lock down and do any of that
they have a different understanding of
how they did in europe oh you mean
places like sweden yeah it's odd when a
guy who thinks aids was airborne is off
about something yeah
try
i hope they do it listen i hope we don't
have all this is true we've talked about
vouching aids you can you know we'll
include it in the description and all
the sources we have are available uh
also the norm clips available lotto
credit.com link in the description but
let's include a link to for people
haven't seen our segment on fouchy and
aids
this is where oprah got that one in five
heterosexual couples would have aids and
then it was airborne that a kid could
get aids in the household if the father
aids
this is dr fauci who hasn't seen a
patient
in half a millennium
just to be clear we the science we don't
know yet but with aids in the that
we don't have long term studies but
the penis connect as an aids nebulizer
you can get it from gay sex
you can get it from sharing needles you
can get it from a child's cough yeah you
can get it from a child's puff for
example if he reaches in the cinnamon
toast crunch with his hand yep this is
why you pour this is why you have balls
jimmy if he reaches in the cinnamon
toast crunch and then the mother reaches
in the cinnamon toast crunch then if
she's pregnant the boy will have
flippers
[Laughter]
and then the box of life is empty just
like their box of love
and kicks
will be kicks the bucket you're all
gonna die all of you
penis nebulizers as you're turning
tricks let's do a serial bit
we don't even need to get into the next
i don't want to talk about more than
vaccine mandates look here's the here's
the deal if you don't understand what
that means just like people say oh tax
of rich more that means take it at
gunpoint what this means is checkpoints
you want checkpoints here in america to
travel from oklahoma to texas that's the
only way to enforce this remember they
said vaccine passports will not happen
how do you enforce vaccine mandates of
course you have to have passports
vaccine passports to go into anywhere
how do you uh how do you enforce
interstate travel you have to have
checkpoints so there's no other way to
well to remind you we did have
checkpoints that's the scary part is
like last year when i was living in new
york they would have soldiers standing
outside waiting and they couldn't have
looked more bored and annoyed with it
but to make you fill out something that
said you would wait two weeks blah blah
blah like that would always happen like
yeah that was already bad wow in new
york in new york yeah and yes and we
need to avoid it happening anywhere
that's not new york exactly yeah they
want to roll that out to a neighborhood
near you i am so glad that new york is
becoming an escape from new york yes oh
yeah and l.a it's the journey escape
from it it deserves it it does it's well
i mean
de blasio's the possibly the worst mayor
in my opinion ever ever
ever worshiped something worse than
kilpatrick worse than coleman young
what wow
coleman young never danced in an empty
time square with his wife
that's the creepiest horror movie thing
i have ever seen it's almost like the
joker dancing into the art gallery yeah
yeah he's just playing prince on a
boombox
who compares that they're like what do
you think's better jack nicholson or
heath ledger it's like oh the guy who
dances with the boombox prince or the
really good actor
oh you're forgetting the circum 30
second to mars singer that's true oh god
he really wants to come back and play
him again yeah i know please no you know
what hopefully there's justice in this
world uh
so the let's go to the what's going on
here with uh can we play do we have the
clip first from romney questioning
lincoln that's clip f2 do you have that
okay so look before we get to millie
there was a blinking questioning here
yesterday yeah and everyone is talking
about millie and i want to talk about
that in a second and i want to hear
where you guys line up and then it's the
rest of the show is going to be a
tribute to norman i do please
not please look you should absolutely do
it
you don't know norm most people don't he
wasn't just funny he was the funniest
but there's a lot more to him and most
people haven't read his book yeah i know
that because i know the sales of his
book you should read his book after the
show nothing would make me happier than
you watching norm clips all day and
everyone else is going to show you the
clip of the moth joke of from norm which
is a great joke that he told on conan it
was actually i think a bob einstein
joker bob einstein and norm are very
good friends they would lift jokes from
each other all the time just to be
really clear everyone's going to show
you the joe uh the the show with uh
what's her name from uh
90210 about carrot top they're going to
show you the espy awards and these are
great great bits
but there's a the bits that youtube
hides from you for example i'm going to
talk about the view it could not be
found on youtube it's true for six years
what yeah so the stuff that you are not
allowed to find when you search for norm
is what we've tried to uh pull out from
the archives for you first also i just
want to say real quick listen to his
book on audible is what i recommend
because it's great it's hilarious yeah i
need to listen to listen to it oh we're
always talking about wow turkey yeah i
don't know yeah which he doesn't drink
oh it's the best like a hunter s
thompson book it's great yeah it is the
funniest book
yeah uh it's completely made up yeah
that's great brilliant and he said some
of it isn't he's like some of it isn't
but i knew that i could only avoid legal
liability if i just said it all was yeah
so before we get to the milly thing i
think that what sets the stage here is
and i know mitt romney you know what it
you know what to do hit it hit it
do you have the the audio come on you've
got to have it right mitt romney what do
we feel about mitt romney romney he
sucks yes there we go
but caught him off he did grill
blinking with some questioning yesterday
yeah and i think this is important
because it'll bring us into the milli
situation let's roll that clip uh of
romney blinken how many of them
approximately so we don't know the exact
number but but how many legal permanent
residents are are we
convinced they're still in afghanistan
we don't we don't have an exact number
but
around the number of thousands pardon in
the thousands in the thousands
in the thousands so this is important
this is important because what and
someone said you need to stop saying
this is important and that's true but
that's because there's a lot of
foolishness that goes on in this show
and then i feel the need to delineate
separate look this is a separate penis
nebulizer from improv right yeah there
we go yeah it's necessary it's
delineation um remember
joe biden said no one will be left
behind none right none will be left
behind man it's america then i told you
on this show
and you can go back i believe it was
last week
might have been a little bit before
where i said look now that we've left
afghanistan and there are at this point
we thought hundreds but now we know
thousands instead of americans and of
course serious allies not not i'm not
someone everyone in afghanistan is not
taliban yeah talking about every ally
who actually helped us but specifically
americans because americans first um the
message will be from joe biden anyone
who wanted to come home yeah
could come home
now admitting blinking on the stand
again when when you can be when there
are penalties for lying that's not true
there are thousands he went on to say
when you include our allies uh romney
said tens of thousands he said i don't
know but it would be a substantial
number so there are thousands
thousands of americans and thousands of
people who helped us fight off the
taliban not to mention how many dogs who
did want to come home who attempted to
come home four months and were blocked
at the airport who are stranded in
afghanistan and that should give you a
pit in your stomach and it should also
scare you that me this guy called it
exactly i told you they were going to
say any american who wants to come home
yeah it's not true and now they admitted
that it's not true that's insane i
haven't i had not heard that i heard the
hundreds right after they kind of
stopped you know doing into the airlifts
they gave the base back over they said
oh yeah there may be maybe hundreds
there we don't have any they never have
an exact number and i understand that
that's hard to get said at least
thousands but at least that so he was
specifically talking about american
citizens said uh in afghanistan because
he said legal permanent residents yeah i
assume he men of the united states right
that were just in afghanistan i would
bring in all i don't know
i can't wait
taliban member in a sailor suit trying
to get on the plane well he's only
bringing in a lot of things like i love
pizza
betty boo what a dish
i'd like to get on plane very nice
reference by the way guys don't ruin it
jim falling back into old habits just
saying ab lincoln
[Laughter]
i love that you said sailor suit when
it's a landlocked country that doesn't
have a name well that's the giveaway
that's how you know if it's actually a
child that's a bearded terrorist
disguised as a child look by the
handkerchief okay they have uh halloween
afghanistan yes they do spirit halloween
and the good thing is if you're a woman
in afghanistan it's halloween everything
it's true but you can only dress as one
thing
one costume yes you can well or if you
technically
it is multi-use as
the kim kardashian met kill out that's
true that's true this is like the steve
jobs
but just put two christmas hams down
your back and oh yeah kim kardashian
met gala she made sex tape stone her
look at her ass
her ass is the laziest
[Laughter]
lazy so that's what happened with
blanken yesterday set the stage for now
millie this is trending yeah and i want
to
show you a clip from cena i want to talk
about going on with millie and then i'm
going to present you and i want you to
hold me to what i'm about to say today
just like i wanted you to hold me to the
fact that biden was saying any americans
who want to come home got home and i
said it was a lie look come back mock me
if i'm wrong about this today
mercilessly going to call it
so
millie and i'm not saying cause everyone
always comes back afterwards and says i
called it today
i'll call it i will tell you exactly
when and what i'm going to call i want
you to come back
and tell me if i am wrong and i will
make a call that i can be verif on which
i can verifiably be proven wrong
hold me to it so uh cnn reported on an
upcoming book written by washington post
reporter uh robert costa and there's
someone else who helped with it the book
alleges that general millie instructed
the military i want to make sure i get
this right not to obey orders
on military strikes without his approval
following january 6th
the book also alleges that
millie actually called spoke
with
top representatives in china i don't
know if you know exactly what was it
supposed to be the chinese
i don't know exactly who it was but it
was higher ups because that's that's
been misreported a little bit yeah but
certainly people in the highest levels
of government if not the top saying hey
we're friends
if
donald trump is going rogue and is going
to try and you know if he might try and
attack you guys i'm going to give you a
heads up
here's the tool treason yes exactly here
they're going to let's show them talk
about it on cnn because apparently there
may be
the reason this isn't a book and it's a
big big deal is
i haven't seen the hard evidence donald
trump himself said that he didn't think
it was true when he was asked in an
interview but if so it's treason cnn
seems to think it's true so i'm going to
call it if they seem to think they have
access to some tapes they have access to
some evidence but they know it's damning
so they don't want you to have it and
only if someone does their due diligence
and investigates what's going on at cnn
these media companies will we ever know
the truth they have something we don't
calling it right now here's them talking
about it he believes trump to your point
is unstable
unpredictable
and woodward and costa right milly
believes that trump is in serious mental
decline
he also has been talking back channel to
the chinese he is aware from
intelligence that the chinese are on
edge because of january 6. that's how i
like my chinese
has the same concerns that millie does
the phone call is dramatic it is blunt
and pelosi wants millie to reassure her
that the nuclear weapons are safe
and this is the exchange
pelosi who knows what he might do he's
crazy you know he's crazy he's been
crazy for a long time so don't say you
don't know what his state of mind is
he's crazy and what he did yesterday
meaning actually two days ago january 6
is further evidence of his craziness
general milley says madam speaker i
agree with you on
everything by the way have you noticed
that every single picture and video of
general milly looks like the ghost of
general milly yes
looks like it's general milly's body
through a wall on frighteners yeah oh
yeah it really does he's definitely got
that white uh and black bag bag yeah
yeah also there's no picture of nancy
pelosi where she doesn't just look like
an old hag or dog yeah well because
they're trying to say that pelosi is
calling trump crazy and um pelosi will
look crazy if you show any picture of
pelosi at all period yeah she says four
times yeah he's crazy he's crazy right
he's crazy huh i can't hear you madam
speaker that's just my blow dryer
the salon ladies turned it up hold on
hold on have to go [ __ ] in the street
gotta keep up with tradition san
francisco
my driveway is covered in bum feces and
that's the way i'd like it
clink clink clink with the trolley
are you just singing show tunes he's
crazy not me
he's crazy i have ice cream
look at all of it he's nuts
speaking of nuts do you like pecan he's
nothing like this four thousand dollar
ice cream that i put in my ninety
thousand dollar freezer huh there's no
business like show business it looks
like every scarf is covering a trach
hole
i should just be on that commercial
where she's like smoking what i have to
do now right like she's gonna have a a
val kilmer equivalent documentary coming
out so yeah oh that was
sad so let me go through treason really
quickly before i present to you how
they're going to
argue this again hold me to it
under us code 18 section 2387
this is uh it defined a member
of the armed forces who
with intent to interfere with impair or
influence the loyalty morale or
discipline of the military or naval
forces of the united states or advises
councils urges or in any manner causes
or attempts
to cause insubordination disloyalty
mutiny or refusal of duty by any member
of the military or naval forces of the
united states so let me give you a few
quick points here okay this is important
that you guys can come in commander in
chief doesn't actually apply to all
americans commander-in-chief applies to
people who are serving the united states
military because their boss is the
president
whether you like that or not if he
issues orders you have to carry out
orders two usurp those orders is
treasonous when we're talking
specifically about treason if you are an
active member of the military let me
also paint to you a picture sort of
pragmatically let's say you're going to
buy a used car and the dealer has he
wants 20 000 he wants 20 000 for the car
and you go in with your top guy you go
in with your second-in-command you say
look i'm probably willing to pay
but i'm gonna start at 15. he goes okay
good so you're on the same page you
understand the negotiation he your
friend says hold on i gotta go to the
bathroom he goes to the car dealer hey
by the way he'll take 17-5 he's just
ruined
all of your he's taken away all of your
leverage now let's use that and apply
bombs apply nuclear weapons apply
life-altering trade deals that's why you
can't have treason now i do think this
is treason and we have i can't say it on
youtube but there's a punishment for
treason in the military look it up
take a wild guess
here's the issue here or this is what i
want you to hold me to i guarantee you
this is how
the media is going to frame this
tell me if i'm wrong they're going to
say well at this point you know general
milly is actually a hero because he was
trying to he was so concerned about
crazy crazy crazy nine times from nancy
pelosi he was so concerned about a crazy
unstable trump that he was actually
trying to protect your constitutional
rights by going around him he was torn
between obeying a president with no
disregard for the constitution or your
rights who was willing to completely
completely bypass
constitutional loans so he had to take
action for the good of the american
people does that's how they're going to
argue it just like they were arguing
every american who wanted to leave could
leave and i told you that wasn't the
case they're going to argue that millie
is a hero who is trying to protect your
constitutional rights against the tyrant
donald trump that will be the argument
now let me ask you if this passes the
sniff test
general milly was trying to protect our
constitutional rights from the tyrant
that is donald trump
by feeding information to china
a nation that affords no rights
let alone a constitution
you believe the hero of the constitution
to accept the premise that the media
will be feeding you that general milly
acted on conscience against an
anti-constitutional president
by going around the back of the
president of the only country that has a
constitution like we have by the way
which includes freedom of speech and
freedom to protect that freedom of
speech
to inform the communist chinese party
doesn't pass a sniff test and don't let
it pass the sniff test when the media is
running with that four weeks until
potentially another shoe drops yeah
absolutely i was watching cnn this
morning trying not to lose my mind
because they're laying the groundwork
for that and saying that this happens
all the time this happened in iran this
happened in north korea and i'm like do
you understand what you just heard on
that call you heard the speaker of the
house
going
and basically becoming the executive
branch
saying
i i don't worry about the president he's
crazy you have to make sure that these
weapons are secured that nancy pelosi
has zero say in if we go to war she has
zero say if we launch nuclear weapons
guess who also has zero say gerald
milley he does not get to approve it if
he does not follow an order from donald
trump by the way the president who
didn't attack anyone and start any war
right so you're now concerned in 14 days
nancy sorry january 12 days that he's
going to do that no that is not how you
run a country and there's a reason that
you don't do that because it's not about
how you feel general it's not about how
you feel nancy about donald trump it is
about the laws that we have set in place
and the processes and procedures to make
sure tyranny does not come back you are
not the president and no matter how bad
you want to be you are not that guy
making the decision and this this is an
amazing thing for people to say is
normal and it's good that he did that no
it's never good to go around the system
like this well even if you believe that
he went around the system he went around
the system to china let's be clear so
there's no going around the system to a
system that will afford anybody more
rights well and what's the best endgame
of that us being destroyed
i mean china's a massive country let's
be honest they could overpower us and
they have our debt right
so why would you do that well and they
hate what we're really wrong
yeah yeah
well the truth is we're relying on a
height advantage when it comes to the
well that's overpowering i know i'm tall
there they're gonna yes i get off the
plane i'm like i'm your king
there's gonna have to throw all their
bodies at our border like world war z
you know they all have the same haircut
it's very similar very very strikingly
you know who is really pissed off about
this though taiwan you know one of the
reasons that china doesn't just take
them back because the united states
military they cannot defend themselves
right john cena yeah he's very very very
sorry right he's gonna come in and
nebulize his steroids that they all
became sterile we're the threat when you
take that away and literally in the book
i think they they were quoting it saying
they were like hey don't listen to the
tweets don't listen to the rhetoric
everything's fine
come on yeah are you serious the people
in taiwan right now are shaking because
they just saw us bail on afghanistan and
leave not only them but ours without the
united states navy taiwan would cease to
exist
of the united states saying china keep
your ass in line yeah
we side with these guys taiwan not with
you donald trump was a lot i wish he
would have been firmer on that but
certainly was more firm than
millie
certainly was more formal than joe biden
okay let's move on here to the norm
mcdonald tribute uh and uh this is i
think this is actually gonna be a lot of
fun before we go into
um some other information of course
deadline reported that norm passed away
uh nine
was it nine
year secret battle nine years of cancer
as he was fighting and he didn't even
tell
his fans or his family
which makes a lot of sense that he would
start a podcast and then stop it yeah
yeah you know what i mean
yeah and he was going he was gonna go
into uh another season i know of his
show i heard right and they pulled a lot
of that off of uh youtube unfortunately
because it's i believe it's now owned by
netflix oh
um i'll probably do a special or
something yeah it's just a yeah it's
just a shame well before any of that i
just want to show this is my uh second
favorite norm joke of all gonna be on
the one that we showed earlier and this
one is very short which shows the
brilliance of norm it can be a long slow
burn or boom catch you off guard that
pattern disruption here you go well a
big seller this holiday season is
michael bolton's christmas album this is
the time
happy birthday jesus hope you like crap
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what i loved about him on weekend update
is he said when he wrote it and you know
like he wrote with a few other people
that were great was he just said just go
for the joke like i don't want to dance
around it i don't want to i just want to
be as blunt as possible and put it out
there yeah that's what i said and by the
way shout out to jeremy boring at the
daily wire that's one of his favorite
jokes too i remember him having lunch
years ago talking about our favorite
norm bits and uh talking about his time
on the view but speaking of his battle
with with cancer it sort of paints a new
light or sheds i should say new light on
this joke that he told i believe it was
in his very in his last special he had
two specials in the last five years he
had hitler's dog and me doing stand-up
right hitler's dog was i think more
recent and yeah me doing something they
were both fantastic i believe
two of the funniest specials ever which
is which is really hard to do when
you've been doing stand-up for so long i
think it was uh don henley who said with
music you know anyone can write their
their freshman album you have your whole
life to write it uh you have six months
to write your sophomore yeah and with
stand-up that's true a lot you'll have
people have an amazing special and then
they don't have another one again that's
when you have people like bill burr
louie c.k who are truly the greats yeah
uh and nor macdonald certainly were look
there are some that are better there are
some that are worse but they are all
fantastic but this
uh i believe i don't know the exact year
but certainly took place in the last
nine years and shows you how indignant
norm was with the media and how he joked
about the face of death that he was
actively facing at the time he told it
the reason i don't like it is because in
the old days they go hey that old man
died now they go hey he he lost his
battle
that's no way to end your life you know
what a loser that guy was
last thing he did was lose
he was waging a brave battle but at the
end i guess he got kind of cowardly with
what happened and then
the bowel cancer it got brave you got to
give it to the bowel cancer
you know
and then
and i'm pretty sure i'm not a doctor but
i'm pretty sure
if the cancer dies i mean if you die the
cancer also dies at exactly the same
time so that to me is not a loss that's
a draw
[Laughter]
what's so great about that bit is you
know it offended people and he had the
card to go well i have cancer but he
never never played it he just because he
believed you could make fun of anything
exactly and he stood by it and i think
that's what really bothers me right now
about him dying is you know for example
when everyone used to show the po the
johnny cash post right of him doing this
right people go oh yeah i love johnny
cash you go no you don't
do you know what hey do you know johnny
cash said you're going to hell
johnny cash sure may have been annie war
johnny cash johnny cash was a rebel
absolutely johnny cash said that if you
rejected jesus christ as your lord and
personal savior you are going to help
period do you know that do you like that
part about johnny well i don't like that
part in other words johnny cash was
rebelling against a culture and sure he
rebelled against some things that maybe
you agreed with when you look at things
like nixon and you understand some of
this his views on war which are not by
the way uh untenable as a christian
but what would be untenable as a
christian is to say oh you know what
there is no hell and it's all good no no
he was very clear that your soul faced
eternal damnation and people just go i
like johnny cash because he gave the
middle finger you don't appreciate what
he was nor mcdonald was unapologetically
pro-free speech defended every turn and
also
he unapologetically attacked
uh
laziness in comedy particularly had a
sore spot when you do the research for
the sort of edgy atheist wave of comedy
yeah he really did which was
especially at that time on nbc to take
that sort of a stance too which i know
we'll probably get into later with that
clip yeah we have that coming up right
yeah he really did though he really
stood against it which was not easy to
do and people began to like you said
that people did begin to turn on him in
the last few years and yeah that's what
i
just find to be disgraceful because it
was always about being funny yeah it was
always about being funny and i want to
hear your favorite norm jokes and how
much you really knew about norm one of
my favorite quotes is actually uh he
said about ricky gervais when he was
being interviewed about his book and he
said you know the thing is there are
only really a few people who are you
know like true stand-up comedians where
they really identify with stand-up uh
you know like people you have people
like louis c.k and people and people
like george wallace you know and i'm not
nearly as highly regarded as those
people he absolutely was yes but he said
but you know then you have people like
ricky gervais where people say uh and he
has these three specials have you seen
ricky gervais his comedy well he's only
done it three times
you know and uh oh oh we get okay the uh
atheist thing there that's new
but he said but of course ricky gervais
is very funny uh the office is
unbelievable peace it's fantastic but uh
is that a stand-up
this was something he would take on all
the time yeah um but let's go back
because a lot of people don't remember
this uh
you may know that he got kicked off a
weekend update for making oj michael
jackson jokes the reason that these
jokes were the last straw is yes because
uh the head of nbc at that time was
friends yes right again the elites with
oj but also they were concerned about
the fact that he was going after michael
jackson so aggressively and oj and it
being seen as potentially racist so
again that's the context you need to
understand back then that a lot of
people now don't remember
because now you're looking at it going
well why would he get in trouble go oj
and michael like we all know no no back
then there was still a huge contingency
of americans who said going after them
was a byproduct of
white nationalism so actually uh that
was during the trial too not right yeah
just that
when he was being when he was on weekend
update making those jokes right like
don't talk about oj he's my friend and
boy did he lean into it until he lost
his job
and it was right after rodney king yep
and it was remarkable and where they
were trying to turn this all into a
racial issue and nbc wanted to avoid it
and so here knowing that context is a
montage during this time of a racial
powder cake seems like we've had those a
lot uh norm mcdonald leaning into it
and the pope came out with a book this
week which contains a series of essays
examining faith and morality in today's
secular world and the changing role of
the catholic church as it approaches the
21st century the book is entitled god
himself told me that o.j is jacob
in his book o.j simpson says that he
would have taken a bullet or stood in
front of a train for nicole
man i'm going to tell you that is some
bad luck when the one guy who would have
died for you
kills you
judge edo was interviewed this week by a
local tv station in los angeles asked by
the interviewer if it was appropriate
for a supposedly impartial judge to be
on tv with his case still pending ito
said maybe not but how appropriate is it
to kill your ex-wife
he'd already been told don't touch it
told police that nicole brown simpson
used to beat him up
he also claimed that she and ron goldman
killed him
o.j simpson's lawyers have decided to
skip hearings on dna evidence and go
right to trial ask why they did this the
lawyers replied we want to get o.j
acquitted as speedily as possible so he
can get back to doing what he does best
killing people
you know it's coming and it's still fun
let's get to o.j o.j simpson's lawyers
say they don't want the families of
nicole brown and ronald goldman in the
courtroom during the trial they're
afraid the presence of the family
members will just remind oj of how much
more killing he still has to do
what i love about norman update was that
he's not even doing that well with the
audience and at the time when i was
young i was laughing so hard i never
noticed until i was a comic yeah and the
other joke i love that he did was uh
he said uh lisa marie presley and
michael jackson are getting a divorce
she wishes he was more of a homebody and
he wishes she was a seven-year-old boy
yeah
i remember too
i remember he said the closest thing he
ever had to a perfect joke and he used
it twice he used it with christy
brinkley and billy joel yeah but uh he
said the most perfect version was uh
julia roberts was she married a lot of
it i love it yeah yeah and he said the
most uh probably the most perfect joke
you know is that i've been trying to
search for it and he really was serious
trying to search for the perfect joke
his whole life yeah the closest i've
come is where you know the punchline was
the same as the setup where i said
uh julia roberts and lyle levitt have
filed for divorce today setting the
reason that they realized she was julia
roberts and he was lyle levitt
and uh that was he what he said was
probably the best joke he had ever
written yeah this is at least a few
years ago i just love his the the
bravery right so his career was on the
line he's being told not to do these
things he'd probably be labeled a racist
you know like you said that that was the
trend that they were heading into and he
just came out and was just like i'm
absolutely going to double down oh he
was getting it definitely hurt him
because he he didn't do as many movies
as his other co-stars did and from no
personnel and it's a tragedy because i
loved him as the lead in dirty work he
was great in that dirty work is
underrated i love it i love dirty work
dirty works original script though the
r-rated version yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think it online is like the
funniest thing i've ever read so just
imagine how funny the pg-13 is yeah but
norm being able to do anything he wants
like him in prison after they you know
oh yeah
yeah he's like you should be a [ __ ] you
know what hurts the most it's like it's
the lack of respect well actually the
anal sex hurt
right after the second most
second
if you haven't seen dirty because we
can't show it we didn't see dirty work
yeah he's sitting there he's pulling up
his pants he's just been raped in prison
hurts the most and has a lack of respect
well except for the other thing that
hurts the most but what's the second the
most is a lack of respect
you boys have a lot of growing up to do
i'm saying that right now
ridiculous
ridiculous
[Laughter]
ridiculous yeah
dude one of my favorite lines in any
movie is just i have to go lift weights
what
what and i love one of my favorite
things of dirty work too is uh the prank
that he pulled in dirty work so there
were these frat boys who oh i love that
beat them up yeah in dirty work and so
there's a scene where uh what they do is
they go into the frat house dressed as
cops
yeah uh but uh they basically tip their
hand that they're not real cops like
uh hi yes we've been uh we're getting
noise complaints i remember exactly what
it was and the guys go uh oh okay we see
what's going on here you know these are
fake cops they kick them out and then
norm calls them on a pay phone and he
goes hey yeah just so you know uh this
is your buddy uh chad he's like chad war
you're not at the party goes yeah i'm
just letting you know there are people
going around dressed as fake cops but
they're not real they're actually and
they're gonna come to you and say it's a
noise complaint they're going to try and
rip off your stuff he's like oh man
thanks for letting us know okay you guys
go back to doing something completely
homoerotic
hello real cops yeah yeah
he calls the cops to the house and these
guys beat their ass and they all go to
prison
and that's what starts his revenge but
just you know exactly the next
five ten minutes of the movie the scene
is hello real cops
i love that he fed uh uh however you
want to call him chevy chase a lot of
the lines that he actually felt like his
gambling addiction went through him
because he was the the doctor that
couldn't stop betting yeah it's like are
you a betting man but he's like you know
when a bookie shoots off your toe you
still have to pay him does that make
sense yeah does that make sense i don't
know
like so is my dad gonna live and ask
actually chevy chase is a funny actor
yes he is my dad gonna live no no no no
but uh
he's very focused on himself but here's
here's the bill
and of course him and farley somebody
put up a picture of him and farley
yesterday and i forgot like that's just
such a great image of two people that
have gone way too oh yeah
i love is a saigon horde
yeah we don't remember dirty work
yeah yeah and i had rough days at a bar
he just goes uh but at least my nose
wasn't bitten off by a psychotic [ __ ]
and then it just shows chris farley
they've already turned around with the
worst negative ever and his nose in half
you
bastard
i'm just joking with you next drink's on
me
g8 street fighting man you hit g7
i'm sorry
underrated film man underrated saigon
[ __ ] that bit my nose off remember
later he's going to this she's like hey
we have to leave in the car he married
the saga or he's
like why don't you shut your high hole
yoko
sometimes the hens got to know who the
rooster is
the saigon [ __ ] bit my new nose
this is probably not good for my throat
but i don't have covered
i just yeah that movie is it's just
brilliant for comic it's like the back
of the room funny but also yeah it's the
it's
arguably the funniest movie ever yeah
and it's like there are cringe moments
where you because it tries so much yeah
that not everything lands but it's young
artie lange and yeah already
donald jack warden uh i forget the name
shooter mcgavin from happy gilmore chevy
chase uh well norm discovered he brought
him on uh well i mean i shouldn't say
discovered but got him to that next
level she's on mad tv and then he
brought him on stern yeah because he had
a lot of great stories so norm was kind
of responsible for artie's career
okay so we have there's so much to get
to i can talk about norm for hours and
hours but um
so you were talking about how dangerous
that was you know the weekend update
stuff he was banned from the view
a lot of you noticed he was banned from
the view and i talked about this back in
my grand rapids studio these clips were
not available for a very long they were
hard to find they were hard the first
time we tried to pull these clips they
were gone so we'll show you it'll sort
of an ascending order him kind of
trolling the view a little bit yeah uh
just you know basically saying racially
tinged things with star jones two
outright
basically when people talk about this
now the clinton body count yeah uh
bringing the clinton murder conspiracy
to the view live on air that's why he
was banned so it's a longer clip but you
need to see this progression he was not
allowed on the view for decades it was
okay what do you think
well i tell you i did love the padres
that's the best part there's just race
in the middle of and i'm a big star wars
fan because
billy williams
i love george bush man he's a good man
decent you know none of this
and he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the see
i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house
a fresh start because we don't want any
more murderers i think we can just go on
to the next question
oh clinton he murdered a guy
you know
accusations without
this is not my week what can i tell you
oh it's not mine either and i'm being
very nice okay
i'd be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that
and i don't want to hear it and this is
not the place to make those accusations
and you're supposed to be funny
it was hilarious
well they keep trying to overpower in
the hand he's too funny don't shut up
all right
let's talk football all right
manslaughter
and by the way
the brilliance here's the brilliance of
that the last line manslaughter okay
there was no conspiracy or accusation of
an accidental death no right in other
words when he says all right
manslaughter as though he's uh he's
being conciliatory there yeah no he's
drawing attention to the fact that this
obviously could only have been
premeditated murder and this is back
george bush george w should just won
so this would have been you know 2000
maybe 2001 yeah really early and oh my
gosh no one was talking about it and i
just remember watching it i must have
been homesick that day i watched it live
oh and i remember going i at this point
there was no youtuber oh my god what am
i where am i ever going to see this
again it was uh it's just so funny
because they kept they they keep going
like he lets them get far enough down
the road where they think they're safe
and on to the next topic and then he's
just like i thought this was mad that
was a matter of recording and you can
tell though that they're frustrated with
him and he's never frustrated with them
no the difference is he just knows that
he he doesn't dislike them he's just
trying to be funny and right and you
know honestly well and to be fair he's
not always a bad like there's also when
you're a guest you'd want to be but it's
they weren't mad that he was being a bad
guest they were mad that he was bringing
up a topic that that was associated well
yeah that he went right to it and well
and they had to take you know the other
stuff they just had to say don't talk
about that and think about he had met
the clintons and the connection with snl
and nbc uh snl and uh the clintons is
huge oh of course absolutely uh and
we've done a whole segment on that it's
pretty much every network these every
single major network in their heads
either if you go to abc nbc cbs cnn you
go from the ceo or network president
just down through vice presidents you
will find someone directly who worked in
a clinton campaign or barack obama
either a speech writer advisor we've
done a whole segment on it you guys run
a search kate mckinnon playing the piano
playing hallelujah as hillary clinton
when she lost
what i mean that's just showing your
hand yeah i know
that was really something she's brave
though
so uh this is something by the way just
so i want you to know um
you know normally donald had a really
had a big impact on on me
um and then we'll get to obviously a big
impact on on on dave but um
so i was fortunate that my mother
who works for the uh this company now
was a uh
i think award-winning a wardrobe costume
designer uh up uh in montreal for the
montreal comedy festival just for laughs
and for people who don't know that's
certain i don't know now there are other
ones but certainly for a time it was the
biggest comedy event of the year i still
think it qualifies but back then if you
made it there it was considered like
you'd made it it wasn't like the tonight
show but it was the closest thing that
wasn't necessarily tell about yeah it
was yeah it used to be that was what
broke you and now
nothing really matters right nothing
really matters it's what can you do by
yourself you know pretty much your own
audience um it's just this is mirrored
in sports it's not necessarily how good
you are like certainly in combat sports
jake paul is demanding more money than
ufc middleweight champion yeah so it's
changed but back then you used to have
to go through the just for laughs and so
my mom would do the wardrobe
and costumes and so one year she could
be having i've talked about this could
be jerry seinfeld could be john uh uh
john candy remember they had a real
panic because john candy was doing a
sketch where he sang the barney song and
this is when barney was pretty new and
they blew him up
uh but they got a letter from the barney
people or pbs so they had to change it
enough
so it wasn't like a a purple barney it
was more of a move
and i remember my mom having to go out
and basically
re-re-fabric this barney outfit so i
just remember all these things as a kid
being backstage and i was allowed to be
either backstage or as a seat filler and
what happens is these executives will
get really expensive seats and they
often don't show up and so if the show
starts and the seats are empty this is
televised in canada so they'll send in
people to fill in two empty seats there
three empty seats there and there are
very few empty seats but it's just you
don't want any empty seats in those
first few rows so i got to watch the set
that got ray romano his show that got
kevin james show i remember seeing jeff
dunham when no one knew who he was when
i was a little kid and this i believe
happened
uh this the the claim is it was 1991
online but i think he either retold it
or they're wrong and it was 92 or 93
because i know i was there both of those
years
and watching from the crowd and i
remember hearing nor mcdonald tell this
show it's not political at all but i
remember as a kid
having really only been allowed to
listen to bill cosby and like jerry
seinfeld not that much at this point
keep in mind i was five yeah uh my
parents may not have been super familiar
with norm stand up because back then
they knew him as the weekend update guy
but maybe didn't know a whole bunch
about a stand-up so i watched his set
live and he had a joke about a man
killing his family because the devil
told him to and it was the first joke
that i had heard with the structure that
was totally different and immediately he
became
one of if not my favorite comedians so i
was watching this live little stephen
crowder in 92 or 93 nor macdonald tell
this joke clip k
man there's crazy guys everywhere i was
reading about this guy in the paper yeah
this folks guy was reading but he killed
his whole family because the devil told
him to can you believe that
what a dork huh
that was the headline the paper said
what a dork
but imagine that you kill your whole
family just because the devil tells you
then afterwards you go back to the devil
go yes devil i did as you instructed i
killed my family slaughtered them as
they lay sleeping and then i i chopped
them up and put them in a duffle bag
here they are in a duffel bag
i'll be burying tonight the shallow
grave by the side of the railroad track
as you have commanded oh lord host of
the hoary netherworld
you know the devil pulls off a mask it's
me bob
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is my face red or what here i
got my family in a duffel bag over here
[Music]
oh there's one for you there bobby
i'm trying to
oh well everybody's one of my favorites
is what he's talking about shallow grace
yeah serial killer yeah cereal
characters like you spent all this time
stalking somebody plotting their murder
eventually finding them killing them
cutting them up then you get to the
burial part and you're like i just throw
some twigs
and move on but it's funny when you
watch norm's specials you can see though
a personal fascination with things like
shallow graves it's a recurring theme
and probably something that scared him
well yeah there's a there is a darkness
too it's what we've talked about in the
show where you make a dark joke and
people are like why i don't know if i
like that it's like well that's why it's
because it is something that's dark that
you're trying to shine some light on or
even work out in your own head yeah well
he has a joke in that special about if
he were a rapist serial killer how he
would capture the woman
yes and it's hysterical because these
people like they always get caught you
know for me if i were trying to you know
uh kidnap and kill a woman i'd be really
coy about it you know i'd uh for example
i would study her uh habits and i don't
want to butcher this because i study
your habits you know so maybe i would
notice that uh let's say every day she
goes to a same sandwich shop you know
and gets these cheese sandwiches and
write that down you know and then after
a while of learning her uh her habits
and her schedule let me see i go to a
grocery store i would pull up in my van
and uh what would i happen to have
but a cheese sandwich
[Laughter]
and i would wait for her to walk out of
the grocery store you know and she'd
walk out and uh
i would say uh hey what do you
what do you got there uh uh what do you
got groceries you would say yeah what's
that in your hand i said oh this
nothing
she said it looks like a cheese sandwich
over there i play really cool and go uh
no that's no cheese sandwich over there
i don't uh
uh it looks like you're holding the
cheese sandwich i love i would say lady
i'd probably know what's in my own hand
i would know if there's a cheese
sandwich in there but oh oh this oh yeah
it is a cheese sandwich
what do you like him or something uh
i got a van full of cheese sandwiches
abducting and killing how he would do it
this was a great bit about how shame the
shame of sex where he's like people put
on leather and he's like they want to
make it more shameful than it already is
yeah he's like you're already closing
the blinds it's not because you're doing
something good in there
he's like and then you finish and you're
like i'm just gonna take off these
leather trousers
go about my day
oh i i forgot to roll clip uh clip j
where he confused larry king and it's
not that hard to confuse larry let's be
honest but uh he was friends with him
though he was yeah yeah him and larry
king actually had a pretty funny dynamic
larry king had zero sense of humor
that's why it was funny yeah serious
confusing uh larry king about a sexual
uh orientation something people don't
know about you
i'm a deeply closeted gay guy
i'm not coming out though
wait a minute
what are you revealing here today i'm
i'm not revealing anything i'm saying
i'm deeply closeted
that means you're gay
well i wouldn't say that why would i say
that i'm deeply closeted
that means you're very very gay but you
don't want to come out you're so
closeted that i refuse to say i'm gay
right
exactly
doesn't that mean you're gay hey hey hey
easy buddy
[Laughter]
hey hey
oh he was the best with people who had
no sense of humor that's when he shines
so funny because
larry thanks for explaining it larry
yeah so
what's your name closeted and means
you're secretly gay my favorite larry
king dumbass moment was with jerry
seinfeld on his show and uh his
interview goes so
cheery
so jerry seinfeld seinfeld
number one show of all time
to be clear
wasn't canceled
jerry someone goes
canceled what
number one show of all time larry can
can someone get larry a resume does
larry know who i am
jew from brooklyn
[Laughter]
next question yeah he just doesn't know
how to deal with it um and this is where
we get into the part of the portrait
that the media will never pay
i would say the funniest man who's ever
lived certainly you could argue it uh
and um yeah you and like i said there's
there's objectively funny you could put
at the top you know people like the
richard pryors and mount russia if
you're having a mount rushmore the
george carlin's you know and no one
would argue with you if you're just
saying i think nor macdonald should be
up there people may disagree but they
won't be like oh that's just so out of
line yeah it's true stand up though
right it's all comedy it's all comedy
but he personally was um
really pretty conservative and later in
life a devout christian and his faith
meant a lot to him this is someone who
struggled he struggled with i think it's
well-known gambling he struggled he
talked about struggling with issues
addiction issues and i don't necessarily
mean substance addiction issues um and
he spoke about his fortune twice yeah
yeah and he's spoken about that and he
would he would actually take unpopular
stances
to speak out yeah see that was a that
was a throat burp jesus i heard that no
that was
autobahn and now i have a sore throat
damn you lamb vindaloo
eating something called lamb vindaloo
it's delicious no it's his fault for
saying maximum spice yeah i don't know
bring the heat yeah you deserve it
when i'm sick i love spicy food it just
helps clear it up yeah yeah it does
still have an [ __ ] okay good it's
still there it's dangling
you know you may want to check your
[ __ ] there make sure you still get
one
get it get it
so um
he was a very devout of conflicted
christian and actually i'll talk about
how you'll see later one of these guys
who he criticizes in the last comic
standing i had on the show
oh
seven or eight years ago
uh harrison greenbaum a gay comedian uh
who norm didn't really like on last
comic standing
but here he is taking opportunities to
express his faith and it pissed a lot of
people off not to mention if you
actually read his writings you get a lot
of attention on twittersphere for being
open about your religious views what are
they
i'm i'm a christian it's not it's about
stylish to say now are you devout
yeah you believe in the lord yes i do
people think you're going somewhere when
it's all when it ends i uh well i i
don't believe it but i you know what
people don't understand about faith is
that you have to uh chooses
you know what i mean they think that you
believe it but you have to choose it i
uh i'm a new yorker i uh
yeah new york
nice
i actually got into an argument on the
subway and the guy quoted the bible at
me that is not fair
like if you get to quote from your
favorite book i should be able to quote
from my favorite book right he was like
men do not live on bread alone matthew's
4 4 and i was like everybody's a little
bit magic harry potter chapter 7.
and you're real brave i mean the stuff
you're talking about bible jokes that's
some brave
thank you
i disagree i don't think the bible joke
is uh brave at all uh
i think if you're going to take on an
entire religion you should maybe know
what you're talking about
jk rowling is a christian
and jk rowling famously said
that uh if you're familiar with the
scriptures you could easily guess the
ending of her book
okay
i don't like it i just want to go
having a nice dream or something you
know yeah where are you going to go
to to die to go with the lord
you believe in lord
i do you do are you religious
i believe in god and i do too that's as
far as i go yeah me too and i don't i
don't need i don't need your buddy bill
maher tell me i'm an idiot people like
they gave you that guy idea the old guy
sure
well why how would we know his nature
yeah but but when i look into your eyes
though
i'm not joking
it's just i've never
had a talk show host say that to me when
i look at your eyes i see and i've done
hundreds of talk shows i see an eternal
being i've never got the answer to the
one question which is why
why
connecticut children why
why a bomber in boston because if god if
there is a god he's omnipotent yeah if
he's omnipotent he could prevent it yeah
why didn't he prevent
i don't know man but you gotta stop
hanging out in that hot tub with bill
maher all the
sounds like you time a god-shaped hole
in your heart
what the hell are you talking about
and that just shows someone who doesn't
know yeah what he's talking about there
he says god shape toll you've heard me
use that term before no yeah it's kind
of ubiquitous and larry king just
but i can't believe it was seinfeld
cancelled
well it's i mean honestly it's it's a
good question yes but it's not that deep
of a question either like balance
we have so many norm clips should we
just keep this should we just do this
right now keep going on youtube or
should we because i don't i almost feel
like it'll be disrespectful to go to a
mug club i think so i said keep going
for a minute okay yeah yeah it'll just
be a little bit of a longer show maybe
we won't have time for the the the crush
game okay we'll do that tomorrow not
every day nor mcdonald dies right well
that was yesterday
do me a favor now the best thing you can
do is is comment for the algorithm uh
pause it and comment and we'll review
these comments to see if you think it
was the right call for us to continue
because i know it's long i just i just
think there's a lot about nor macdonald
that you've missed and i want to give
him the respect that he deserves also
uh
smash that like button uh if you can
because that also helps smash you know
smash it for norm well get yourself one
of these nice mugs here man no let's not
use this death to sell mugs no well you
need to get light storm i'm not saying
that i'm just saying that normally we
would go to something that's behind the
scenes now yeah that's true uh do we
have the montage too that because i
realized i wanted to hit this or not
montage the bit
that dave said was a big influence where
he talks about uh alcoholics anonymous
it's one of my favorite it might be my
favorite norm bit ever and let people
know too that's because you've i mean
well i can't say what i'm in but i think
we know you're in a uh multi-step
program i'm in recovery and one of my
favorite things that he ever said about
gambling was yeah it's a disease but
it's uh the only disease where you win
money
by the way have you watched louder milk
on amazon i have it's great it's great
yeah it's really good will sasso
especially i know yeah he's fantastic
and i think i think rod livingston is
cool yeah he's always good but i will
say so like i just think has that
character that brings it to this next
level it is it's for people who don't
know it's a show it's and by the way and
guarantee you it has a yeah it reserves
the emmy yeah has a conservative writer
and they're a conservative creator
and it's balanced it makes fun of trump
a couple times but it also makes fun of
the lgbtq aip gender pronouns political
correctness it's one of those shows that
is as balanced and an equal opportunity
offender that i can possibly think of
and so it seems appropriate while
talking about norm to mention that show
louder milk on amazon because hopefully
it'll have a fourth season i would say
one of the best the best comedy that i
can think of of the last few years we
have that clip there all right this is a
clip and uh you can just tell us when to
stop it did cause we didn't bring this
into the trick yeah it's a longer clip
but if you just see the first minute or
two you kind of get where where it is
here we go brilliant
hello my buddy i did want to say one
thing about my buddy richie who has a
disease
and uh but it's it's an interesting
disease he has he has a disease of
alcoholism alcoholism
and he came to me you know and he told
me and uh i like to look i'm the kind of
guy that likes to look at the bright
side of things you know so i told him i
said richie it's true that you have a
disease and everything but
i think you got the best one
it's the only disease where you get to
drink booze all the time
i haven't looked at every medical
journal but i believe
it's the only disease where you can
constantly drink booze
as a matter of fact that is the disease
[Laughter]
you know i don't think richie would
think he had to just like i don't think
richie would go to my uncle bert go hey
i understand you got bowel cancer ah man
i know how you feel i gotta
drink a lot of booze those diseases
they're tough those diseases uncle
burt what's your symptoms uncle bert
well my bowel i got blood pouring out of
it all the time i got bowel blood
pouring out gushing out of my bowel
almost nonstop and
i got searing climb pains
ripping tearing you know uh
mind
screeching
bowel pains
and uh they're combined with aching
dull soul deadening battle pain
those are basically my symptoms how
about you i get happy
and
i love that bit just because he's
speaking from a point of an addict right
and just saying how preposterous it kind
of is but at the same time you know he's
right i feel serious about it yeah and i
love when he talks about going to aaa
where he's like so you uh
because you go into a church basement
and you give everybody your name which
doesn't sound that anonymous
and you only give him the last letter
because you don't want him to know who
they are you know and then he just it's
just brilliant i don't want to butcher
it but he's like then you tell everybody
yeah you blew a dog from pine and gin
but he just goes and who better to trust
than a room full of drunks
and you know what's funny is you could
just this is
when i've talked about this before norm
is a litmus test because you could be an
alcoholic
or someone who's an alcoholism
advocate alcoholism advocate and be
offended by that i'm sure some are yeah
there are plenty of people who have been
or can be like you and say that's a
brilliant way to turn it into a take
something painful and turn it into
something funny norm really tried to
push people's buttons he wasn't these
weren't anti-jokes people have sort of
misrepresented that they were jokes they
just happened to be jokes that push your
buttons sort of like an alice cooper and
that's why i think they're very similar
alice cooper learned how to push your
buttons and so did dio you know dio back
then talked about imagery was like well
how well how do you think that's satanic
how do you know what satan looks like
with that image and how do you know that
that priest is the good guy you're the
one who's conferred this sort of
this meaning to this imagery and nor
macdonald allowed people to copy paste
what they thought on to him and so
people would be offended or be brought
tremendous joy by the exact same bit
well something i took from that too was
just it was almost like cautionary i was
like oh well yeah you i guess at the
beginning of the day like if i choose to
start drinking like i know you can have
a proclivity for it or a tendency to get
addicted to things i get that but it's
like huh that guy didn't choose to get
cancer right
there's a slight difference here right
yeah any well even if we played it uh
for another second i forgot about the
line where he just goes and i find it
easier to talk to people yeah
and you know uh dennis miller who was
good friends with norm and i i love
dennis and it's funny you know dennis
miller adam sandler norm spade all
friends and they none of them
were conservatives when they were
younger they all became conservative as
they got older i don't know about spay
maybe he's neutral but he's certainly
not liberal he's fine i think i think
he's a conservative when he donates
millions of dollars in ar15s to the lapd
yeah come on come on but uh norm uh
dennis miller had a similar bit about uh
you know relapsing as an alcoholic you
see that's that's gotta be you know that
isn't necessarily the worst day of your
life friends going hey what's wrong with
you i got the disease back man
i'm riddled with it
that's why they all you know they all
experience this
a level of addiction and i mean harley
was their good friend who was the prime
example of when you take in everything
yeah right you know and and i think uh i
think david spade is more swimming in
his sex addiction yeah
i'm just guessing but spade is one of my
favorite comics too and they all really
good dude he's a brilliant stand-up and
people don't realize that his last hour
special is one of the funniest ones i've
seen you know who's also has really has
really great stand up but doesn't write
a ton of new material but has never done
a special is bobby
who bobby lee bobby lee i don't know
bobby lee's stuff i've heard good things
you haven't done a special well i guess
i would have seen her like uh oh i've
done like 20 minute one yeah nothing no
i haven't i wanted to do a special but
we could do this special i'll do it if
you want to i mean what you want
otherwise you want to go to comedy
central good luck i well no i i did uh
this is not happening uh 17 years ago
and this is not happening is anytime
i've asked for a special right
no we could look hey guys comment
we could do it we could uh i don't know
how we would do we could release it on
mug look when we show up we show up at
smu mcfarland auditorium is what 2400
people people have been turned away yeah
i guarantee you we can tape a special
and find a way to distribute it there's
no reason to wait for anyone else to be
in dallas at the majestic in fact well
no no we need a planet well that would
be a plan the point is i'm not i'm not
giving them commission fees to the chest
you guys should rent out your own
theater and do it yeah yeah no maybe it
could be majestic but yeah but i just
want to figure out what's best for you
what you would be happy with and how we
can distribute it would you guys love to
see dave special out there dave davis
dave is obviously
obviously dave is great at what he does
he's very good uh he's a very good
standard community and i would readily i
would say of course i did i did stand up
and i did i had started acting before
stand up and so my stand-up was very
performative and really after this show
my stand-up improved and then when i was
in grand rapids i pretty much just
stopped because
i they wanted me to do bringer shows
after i'd already done them just for
laughs and these other shows i was like
worse but it's because you moved to a
new town so anyways and i just i i
always got really stressed dave is a
great stand-up community and david
dave's shows are all a little different
because dave is
great stand up but he is the best person
thinking on his feet as you can see in
the show of anyone i've ever seen anyone
that i've ever seen and i don't think
that's an insult to you when i say nor
mcdonald's funniest man who ever lived
no nick apollo to me probably one of the
funniest stand-ups i think he is and
then but quickest on their feet is you
well thank you and i haven't seen all of
your stand-up though because every time
if i want to go to one of your live
shows then i get mobbed i've noticed
that yeah so i don't like to they like
you they have to touch you they like to
do they like to touch and give me they
like to give me uh food and cigars that
i could never ever trust
no offense no offense it's true it's not
the best idea maybe a gift certificate a
cigar is so easy because the wrapper's
so thin just with a needle i know i
smoked one of the cigars the guy told me
to give you and i [ __ ] my pants and woke
up three days later
in tijuana
um okay so and this is one thing too i
have a long history in talking about nor
mcdonald uh i think we have a clip here
just so you can kind of see how
important of an influence we actually
got i i stand with norm trending because
they tried to cancel nor mcdonald i
think it was
two years ago yep maybe with three years
ago and this is when everyone had turned
on him he had always been my number one
guest i wanted to get in the show uh my
white whale um so here's kind of a
timeline
just so you you can see how much much
he's he's meant to the show and his
presence has been known even though he's
never been here let me say this
emphatically nor mcdonald is the most
important voice in all of comedy today
period bar none the reason that hashtag
i'm with norm which is what i'm calling
is so important he's not just a comedian
he's a veritable authoritarianism
weather stick he's a comedian with the
single most stellar track record for
speaking
using comedy uh to shine a light on on
the real taboos of our time you know
here to simplify it if norm mcdonald is
pushing back against something that
tells you that it's wrong whatever it
may be this is for me the line in the
sand because this is somebody who has
consistently risked it all he has
consistently been right he was
consistently praised for it until all of
a sudden he's done it with the wrong
this is why hashtag i'm with norm this
is shocking because no one says what
norm says because it's really easy to go
up and make jokes about christians in
new york it's really easy to go up and
make middle americans seem stupid so
because no one says what norm says it's
shocking because all of a sudden being a
christian more right wing is more we
talked about
what was edgy in comedy everything you
just did was character assassination on
myself and norm people booed him he
didn't get the joke i didn't say any of
those things to you being a political
pawn cause number one product sales
coming second
network loyalty coming third and then it
could be argued maybe on a good day
comedy coming in fourth on the list and
when you contrast that with comedy
of yore and comedians of your like nor
mcdonald's well i think norm himself
said it best you know if you really want
to be
really funny
then that's that's what you want to do
you want to think what would make seth
meyers laugh
that's how i live my life that's when we
were writing this bit we couldn't get
away from it sounding like norma
mcdonald in our head so we're going to
do this as a nor mcdonald joke uh all
right harold again
all right so uh today is the birthday of
uh you know both michael jackson and
ingrid birdman uh one captured the
hearts of millions in her portrayal of
isa london the classic film casablanca
uh filmed some of called the apex of
cinema the other was a homosexual
pedophile
so you know
i'd like to have sex with kids there you
know
yeah all right end to norm tribute we'd
love to have you on the show north uh
yes please please well i felt that way
about conan when when he's had comics on
even norm one time he kept interrupt
he's like how long has this bit and he
doesn't know that norm sets these things
up and then reels you win you know when
he had the the beverly hills nine on two
one was like uh you have to do a movie
with carrot top because yeah it should
be called box office poison
yeah colin kept interrupting him and i'm
sitting home going will you let him it's
obviously a [ __ ]
it was the same episode he got cancelled
uh back then and i mean actually
abandoned from the view because he said
uh george bush had just become president
and he said he said yeah yeah it's good
to get a good guy in the house and get
murderers out of the white house you
know and then what murder he goes hey
bill clinton didn't you know he killed a
guy
and they banned him for life but in that
same show he talked about going to the
friars club he's my favorite you talked
about going to the friars club and this
was on i remember watching with my dad i
just i love you normally i was a
different kid and i'm watching with my
dad and i remember sitting there crying
he says you know i go to the i don't
know if it was a friar's club it was
something like that where i get invited
to this you know club you know and uh
they uh they tell me you know are you
gonna go there and hang on it's kind of
you know oh you know barbara it's a
roast right and uh but then i realized
when i get there it's all these old
communities but not that good comedian
not like bob hope for milton berley you
know like uh like a frank travolina
and then i realized i said like hey this
guy over here uh you know somebody asked
me if i want whiskey or something and he
goes he can't have any you know and i
realized that every joke is a about me
being a homosexual man
yeah and i'm not a homosexual man as you
well know says meredith vieira right
away she's stunned
realized that's how they you know
there's other timers inside the unit so
i uh it's turned over to uh uh i think
it was frank traveling because i turned
into frank and i said uh you know uh he
likes uh having sex with guys you know
and all he did was he looked at me like
this
you know
that was all he did
[Laughter]
and it was you could hear a pin drop
i had to shorten it but i realized i
said he can't drink whiskey yeah no he
probably is not defending the ladies ah
hey guys jokes i'm playing i'm a
homosexual man
that reminds me in 2018 they tried to
cancel normal what was that for do you
remember that uh actually we have it uh
we we have that uh we're talking about
that uh here in a little bit um you know
yeah well you just go back to to that
now that was when louis ck find himself
in um in hot water oh yeah and and
here's the thing
with louis ck and look
i i think that look louis c.k is a
well-known kind of liberal in some
aspects and he didn't really stand up
for people who needed to be who needed
defending at some points yeah however
i think we need to draw the line between
him for example is he's in sorry and
ze's i'm sorry he's a woke social
justice warrior who's called for the
scalps of other people yeah i don't
think aziz i'm sorry sexually assaulted
anybody i read that story we need to
separate from the bill cosby's of the
world and the bad dates louis c.k you
could argue an abuse of power and i've
joked about this on this show you'd have
to go way into the archives past even
harrison greenbaum about him during
masturbating in the green room
it was well known in the comedy
community uh his the accusations against
him were that he would service himself
in the green room and ask women to watch
but there were there weren't people who
were saying that he like blocked the
door right or salt but they were added
though that was added later it was added
later yeah that was added later but the
idea was they felt uncomfortable and it
was an abusive power and it is and it's
weird however everyone sexually is into
stuff that maybe someone else might
consider we consider the point is you
don't no one wants your sexual details
revealed to the world yeah now in my
case it's entirely monogamous with one
woman and so whatever it is can't be
that embarrassing in his case it was
with as many people who would watch him
fap in the green room um
but comedians started calling for his
scalp yes louis ck
and norm was one of the few people who
stood up and defended him and that's
when people came after norm so i think
we have that uh yeah clip
comedians have
gone up against louis
yeah
well
i mean i was talking to some communities
who said he this guy should not be able
to ever perform again but it doesn't
mean you you you can't forgive or it's
impossible to forgive
i also don't feel um
anyone owes me an apology
in in in public you know
um
i i i think
personally that you owe an apology
to
anybody that you
did ill to
you owe an apology
to people
that your
actions hurt in a financial way or an
emotional way
uh but nobody owes me an apology you
know
that used to be called
yeah yeah sure yeah yeah
uh and he talks about forgiveness too
it's like it seems like that's a concept
that we've forgotten in society and yeah
there used to even be a redemption yeah
that was a part of society and now we
don't want that we just want to destroy
right it's just sacrifice after
sacrifice
real apologies and you know contrition
too i guess is the start of that and we
don't see a lot of that we just see like
oh well well it's who does louis ck own
apology too i mean if anybody okay you
said yes you let him do what he did it
is what it is maybe it's regrettable now
and maybe you should apologize for that
but at the same time you know to act
like people are powerless when sarah
silverman and janine garofalo and all
these other comedians that come forward
for louis you know you have people
extremely liberal like you said yeah
seriously kind of backtracked though
yeah but well yeah i guess
i guess but i mean she still took a more
noble stance than some open mikers right
yeah i know that's the problem there's
all these open mics who go after them
who just want to sort of and this is
also what you're seeing right now with
norm and i think everyone should
obviously
honor norm and him passing but now you
have people who were on the other side
of these issues
in opposition to norm now i've been like
oh yeah i thought he was great right and
uh he has been one of the biggest
influences on this show period i used to
tell people i was when people used to
say and if you look at some of the jokes
that we've written or that we've told on
the show you can clearly see the yeah
um
david letterman and john that's how i
used to describe it to people i would
say david letterman meets kind of john
stossel and then there's a little bit of
early howard stern and the you know
sense of humor nor macdonald is always
you know you think he's the funniest
person ever yeah so that would be sort
of
the four-person mix of what probably
influenced this show the most yeah
you've talked about that several times
with me because i didn't grow up
watching a lot of comedy i watched a
little bit of snl and then i just kind
of broke away so i saw some of those
things about oj that he said
pretty much around the time but yeah
always talked about like these are the
guys that really have influenced you in
the show and i know that's the so many
people out there i just didn't have that
perspective on how much he had done
until honestly this well and you know
what and this is i want to bring me to
my last point
um
there is a common thread if you look at
not only what what we do here but my
biggest influences okay let's just take
that norm
david letterman
john stossel
and i did what one thing have all of
them that early letterman yeah the
common thread that they are is they all
poked their finger in the chest of
authority from david letterman daring
nbc to fire him or sorry cbs to fire him
right showing up at the ge studios there
with fruit baskets and then kicking him
out of
his own office
norm mcdonald poking his finger in the
chest of nbc you can't tell michael
jackson jokes you can't tell oj jokes
but i guess you should watch and then he
did it john stossel john stossel was
reviled at abc john stossel went against
the grain and went from consumer
reporting to reporting on government
corruption
and whether you like what we do or not
look
youtube and google is the most powerful
company that's ever existed
number two through five would be amazon
apple
facebook twitter right so that's the
authority you think that the media is
fans of us we have content so there's
always been an influence for me i've
just always found it funny when someone
the gesture pokes fun at the king and
that whether i realize it or not in the
formative years is also what turned me
into a problem child
but not in the sense of you know i
wasn't doing drugs and stuff like that
and it wasn't like harming people but i
had a strong sense of justice but i had
no respect for authority if i thought it
was ill-gotten which is wrong with me
don't get me wrong but like i would just
like you'd have in my report card
pleasure to teach pleasure to teach
these were teachers who are respected
and disruptive and or abusive in class
as a comment and i was like well yeah
that teacher is an actual communist and
i'm not just misusing it she says she's
a communist that it works beautiful in
theory and so every time i go into drama
class i take a big gold stephen [ __ ] on
her
my dad was like you shouldn't do that
but
okay that's drama class
come on
uh here's some quotes so too from norm
defending free speech and criticizing
sort of the modern uh
like you're talking about modern
comedians he says
uh if you can tell me one funny socially
relevant joke
i'd give you a million dollars uh
comedians when they get really good and
nowadays they don't even have to get
good reach a point where they feel they
should be philosophers i've heard it
said even that the modern day
philosophers are comedians i read modern
day philosophers
i'm sure they're insulted when they're
compared to people who work in smoking
nightclubs and hit on waitresses for a
living if you're watching a comedian on
television he's making a political point
i would say he's gotten too serious
which is ironic because he would do it
but he would do it through comedy yes in
other words you have to read he would do
it in a way that was funny as opposed to
someone like
a trevor noah or a stephen colbert
well he's saying just making the point
yeah just making the joke yeah where
they've decided that is their most
important uh you know modus operandi why
i never have a point
the model used to be
admit wrongdoing show complete
contrition and then we can uh give you a
second chance talking about the two and
the forgiveness now it's admit
wrongdoing and and you're finished and
so the only way to survive is to deny
deny deny
and that's not healthy
it's not healthy because uh
there's no forgiveness
and that ties up
i think everything that makes
norm
norm right there in that comment what do
you have you have the point of view of
someone who obviously uh thinks that
comedy should be funny
and he thinks that or at least he used
it to poke fun and authority um and he
thinks that uh he doesn't use the term
cancel culture he's more articulate than
just saying cancel culture or anything
it's wrong to treat people this way
um
and the reason it's wrong is because
we have a society where we're looking
for scalps there's no forgiveness and
where does that stem from where does all
that stem from that stems from a world
view of norm macdonald that he has a job
to do
and his job is not to go out and tell
you know have a pity party over his
cancer which i think a lot of us would
have liked to know how much time we had
left with him but this is how norm lived
his life whether you liked it or not his
job was to be a comedian
you only got to know what he wanted you
to know about him
and he wanted you to know that he
thought we were heading down the wrong
path
in the entertainment industry in comedy
and a big reason because of that
is because we've lost the forgiveness of
someone who someone and an influence was
very important in his life
of god
that's where that world view comes from
without god the
glory shaped hole in your heart
larry king there can be no forgiveness
and i just think that norm mcdonald
people come out and just show one or two
jokes really miss and under appreciate
who he was what he did and the mark that
he left not only on this show not only
in this little world but the world as
you know it in a bigger way than maybe
you realize so uh let's leave and then
go to youtube norm
i think i i think we i speak for all of
us here we say we miss you and it was
the world lost a good one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign